did you enjoy doing good burger too I
loved it oh my go shout out to like yeah
he was here yeah so wait doing it like
years later that's so awesome it's
amazing I mean a 26 year Gap is just
like really hard to imagine yes but you
know we both look very young still so
that's good and uh people seem to enjoy
the movie so like we couldn't be prouder
like it was a a great response and you
know great support from Paramount
niclodeon and yeah it just feels really
good we did the parade I going ask you
about do you like doing that cuz I've
done the pray before it's cold it is
cold yeah but it was incredible so much
love and you forget New York is full of
buildings that you know are very tall
and there's people in the Windows like
all the way up so like riding for a mile
through the middle of the city where
people just waving and smiling it was
incredible like yeah that was us out
there and shout out to those mechanics
cuz they got that car to work the whole
time it's always like it looks good but
like will it run it's an older car so
they did a good job where what was like
your favorite um I asked Kela what was
your favorite burger place like as a kid
or even now what's your favorite growing
up I feel like I was big
on
McDonald's oh my God my son is addicted
yeah and then I went to LA and tried in
and out and that was good yeah but I
don't eat red meat anymore so we tried
heart house recently and that was that
was really good Kevin Hart's spot I
don't know I didn't do eat red meat for
like one year and it was the saddest
year of my life yeah yeah it's it's a
dearly departed friend and you know I I
look at my friends kind of like the
little kid looking from the window that
can't go outside yeah yeah that's like
when I see my friends having a milkshake
cuz I'm lactose intolerant and I'm just
like just tell me can I smell it yeah
I'm just like no alternative I mean
there is is it as good no so why even go
there yeah get out of here feel you yeah
I tried like lactose free eggnog this
like holiday season get out of here
nobody wants just nog yeah there's no
segue
[Music]
[Applause]
there thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home